let me walk you through what this
question is suggesting okay so um and
I'm gonna have to remember my own purse
it's quite complicated here is the setup
this is just the setup okay you've got
ABC which is any triangle you like and
they then join up all these cords and
this this guy over here by the way this
is not a tangent it doesn't just touch
the circle it cuts right through I don't
remember what that's called
that's when yes this is a secant okay
it's a secant so you've got all these
and then you've got these perpendiculars
I've drawn them in red now you can see I
used quite a few colors and I'm gonna
use even more because colors help me to
see through the question they help me
focus on different layers of the
question at different times so what
they're suggesting is that XY and z are
I rubbed it off the board but this is
just in the x y&z are collinear alright
so they're for something like this is
the case I'm just going to cheat a
little bit actually I'd make it a bit
bigger you guys have rulers I don't have
a ruler on here so I'm just going to use
the fact that this thing can draw
straight lines which is totally a cheat
sorry and there you go there is the
straight line that they're talking about
right so they're trying to suggest that
if you draw those perpendiculars you
will get this straight line keep in mind
and this is why on your book it's a
dotted line I think you don't actually
know that this is a straight line you've
got to be careful between what you know
and what you have proven to be true
they're not the same thing
okay but what I'm setting out for is to
prove that's a straight line that's my
goal
okay so here's my first suggestion and
if you've got another color I'm going to
focus on a Z D and why I want to prove
that those guys up there up in that
corner
Arkan cyclic okay how am I going to do
it I'm going to directly use the result
that we prove just like 15 minutes ago
which is that if you have a look at
angle a yd have a look at angle a yd can
you tell me its size it's 90 it must be
and the reason for that of course is
because
it's up yet well these are
perpendiculars the red lines are all
perpendicular or angles on a straight
line you've got 90 on the other side
okay but if this is 90 and you already
have this being 90 up here tell me what
did those angles there I'll highlight
them for you
what do a Z D and angle a yd add up to
180 degrees but we just showed that if
the opposite angles of a quadrilateral
are supplementary like this then you
have four consecutive points you have a
cyclic quadrilateral does that make
sense so that's all I needed to show
that a Z and Y are concise like the
opposite angles are supplementary I'm
done okay so therefore if you have your
compass there here's one I prepared
earlier so yes I know convenient right
I'm gonna have to fiddle with the size
for the next one though because it's
gonna be different there we go
now do it there's AZ dy okay hey Zed d1
now at this point I need to prove a
property that's on your sheet but I
haven't proven it for you but it's very
very simple so just bear with me if you
want to maybe off on the side here draw
it drilling like a little circle I don't
know why I did that I have a perfect
circle right here there we go okay now
if you have this other circle you can
draw angles that do this they stand on
the same arc so for example if I named
an arc over here let's call this guy a B
okay you can draw a bunch of angles that
stand on this arc say something like
this this guy over here can you see that
this angle stands on rkb does that make
sense but that's not the only arc that
stands on our sorry not the only angle
that stands on our KB I could draw
another one say over here let's put this
guy over in the corner
this angle I've just drawn down here
also stands on arc a B now when you have
a look at that angle and if I draw a
third one it should be even more obvious
when you have a look at all three of
these angles standing on the
circumference what do they look like
they look like they're the same right
and in fact that's why I've labeled them
as such how can I prove that they are
the same it's really really
straightforward watch this the
construction that always yields the most
in sight is the center and some radii so
if I put the center in there and connect
up some radii like so let's call the
first angle that I drew the very very
first angle let's call that feet up okay
if that's theta forget about these guys
for a second what's the red angle have a
look the red angle in here the red angle
in here clearly has to be 2 theta right
do you see why because it's the angle at
the center standing on the same arc as
this angle at the circumference it even
looks like that that's one of the
advantages of circle geometry a lot of
things look that like they are true so
that guy is 2 theta now if that's 2
theta I'm gonna put these guys back now
if this guy is really 2 theta now forget
about the original angle what's this
purple angle it has to be theta for the
opposite reason right this is still
another angle at the circumference
standing on the same arc right so
therefore it's you've got that doubling
relationship so this guy over there is
Theta and in fact that guy will also be
theta because they're all standing on
the same arc or subtended by that right
so therefore when you come back to this
guy and we'll get rid of the red one now
it's not just that they look alike they
really are alike so the wording that you
would put for this and actually I'm
gonna pitch the sheet so I give you the
right order of words so if you got on if
you have this guy the way you would say
this is angles and the word I kept using
was standing right remember those legs
picture the legs angle
standing on the same arc what what are
they they're equal are equal an
alternative way to word that is that
angles in the same segment are equal and
that's what I put in the brackets on
your page segments are equal okay now
we're going to use this fact okay I'll
come back to this wording if you want it
so don't worry if it's disappearing
we'll come back